taking over a small hotel close to the
athletes village in tokyo
south korean chefs prepare meals for
their entire olympic team
it's aimed at keeping them more isolated
during the pandemic
but also to make sure no local
ingredients
carry radiation from the fukushima
nuclear plant disaster 10 years ago
we have put more effort in this time
because of the coronavirus concern and
because people are quite sensitive over
the origin of
ingredients such as those from fukushima
certainly the team members are all in
favor of the special menu
because they screen the ingredients i
prefer to eat more of this as i think
it's safer
but the food program has irritated many
in japan
which insists all its food is safe given
the long and troubled relationship
between japan and south korea
it doesn't take much to bring old
animosities to the surface
and the olympics has offered ample
opportunities
to do just that starting with the torch
relay
months ago the official map of japan
with the relay route
showed a tiny group of islets which are
disputed by the two neighbors
as being japanese known as dokdo in
south korea
a banner proudly proclaiming them to be
korean
hangs prominently opposite the japanese
embassy in seoul
before south korea's winter olympics in
2018
the same islets were initially shown as
being part of the korean peninsula
then a possible bridge-building visit to
tokyo by south korea's president moon
jae-in
was ruled out amid a controversy over
insulting remarks
made by a senior japanese diplomat and
back in the olympic village a banner
apparently evoking a 16th century korean
victory over japan
had to be removed following complaints
two old adversaries proving they are
happy to go head to head
whether olympic medals are involved or
not rob mcbride al jazeera
seoul